on va faire une interview oui non et
vous ne répondrez amanda lear que par
oui ou par non
en bouche
en bouche musicale
vous avez bougé dans le gymnase saint
jean peut rallumer je suis désolé ok on
allume heures désolé
on va faire une interview oui non
en bouche holding
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien
amanda lear si vous trompiez votre jules
est ce que vous lui diriez non
est ce que vous croyez en dieu oui
est-ce que vous donnez dans la rue à
ceux qui font la manche oui
parce qu'elle est rue que vous refusez
de fer au lit
oui quoi
je me suis plié j'ai moi même bien sûr
tous piégés olala j'aimerais le savoir
il ya des trucs dégoûtant brawn on a
mûri à la manga mais c'est vrai c'est ce
qu'on dit à chaque fois mais on
s'embrasse sur la bouche avec la langue
de trucs comme ça un peu cramé il ya des
trucs et un monde plein de gens aiment
faire et moi par particulièrement quoi
un exemple la vaisselle
c'est très coûteux a des poils plein les
dents
avez vous réalisez vos rêves d'enfants
non quand même ça fait le plus beau
parent président la république far tu
aspire à devenir enfin quand je dis tu
es sûr que tu voudrais être
brain président un jour
non amanda est ce que vous avez déjà eu
des expériences diensten sexe vous
rencontrez quelqu'un vous rencontrez
quelqu'un à brit-brit une demi-heure
après c'est dans les chiottes du
restaurant brune de miers d'accord bas
c'était s'est emparé ainsi un raptus
dans l'ascenseur ça vous est arrivé déjà
tam est arrêté aimeriez-vous devenir
amanda lear la maîtresse d'un chef
d'état oui
avis aux amateurs
jean le pouvoir que tu as c'est toi qui
dirige parce qu'il fait tout ce que tu
lui as mandat avez vous déjà connu la
dépendance sexuelle
oui non mais ça c'est quelque chose de
terrible
rogge ce oui qu'on dit ce mec gelé dans
la peau à adé qui me touche ça pose à sa
bouche et tous et c'est dramatique
vous écrivez souffre terriblement
est ce que vous croyez amanda lear qu'il
ya quelque chose après la mort oui
des composés si
vous avez déjà fait l'amour à 5 à 5
non c'est beaucoup c'est un examen des
soustractions
attend à cinq de base et la taille du
nid
à quatre noms à trois temps aa
oui ah oui 4 oui oui 4 oui oui il y
avait des femmes non
des animaux
amanda lear avez vous plus de qualités
que de défauts non
oui y at il un fantasme que vous n'avez
pas réalisé oui ma fille
en même temps en même temps c'est
marrant c'est vrai il faut qu'il faut de
toute façon qui est toujours un fantasme
non réalisés parce que maintenant quand
on a réalisé tous ses fantasmes d'abord
on a plus que des bons souvenirs c'est à
une décevante asthme et puis la vie est
restée faut toujours espérer encore de
faire quelque chose amanda lear est ce
que vous vous aimez non pas encore tant
qu'à venir ça va venir je travaille là
dessus avec mon psy juste c'est pas
jérémy verbe c'est non bien sûr elle a
dit qu'il prenait son enfant
est ce que vous feriez un film porno
pour un million de francs
non 2 millions non mais j'y mourrai posé
la question il ya 15 ans j'aurais dit
oui parce que je trouve que j'étais
encore photographia le nord maintenant
ça vieillit joly dont elle va partir
d'un certain âge je trouve quand même et
des hommages
millions de francs
novembre
les 100 millions je pourrais pas payer
arrête non j'ai pas de la revue poli
alors mineure
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu